the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hi today we're going to study something
called the hyperbolic functions and in
the sense we're going to show that in a
very major way the study of the
hyperbolic functions mimics the study of
the circular functions and so in a sense
what we will do is parrot much of what
we did for circular functions to wind up
with our hyperbolic functions since the
basic difference between a hyperbola and
a circle is a sine namely x squared plus
y squared equals 1 versus say x squared
minus y squared equals 1
I've entitled today's lesson what a
difference a sign makes now by way of
brief review recall that the circular
functions originated as follows we said
consider the circle whose equation is x
squared plus y squared equals 1 that's
the circle over here
then what we did was picking this as a
starting point and taking any length T
we wrapped T around the circle when the
length T terminated at Point P we
defined what cosine T 2 equal X and sine
T 2 equal Y that was basically the
geometric interpretation of the circular
functions after which we showed that
there was a physical meaning to this as
well now you see what we'd like to do is
the same thing only with regard now to
what I will call the hyperbolic
functions and you may recall that in our
lecture on circular functions
I mentioned the hyperbola very briefly
now I'd like to go back to the hyperbola
in somewhat more detail namely we now
look at the equation x squared minus y
squared equals 1 see just to change the
sign over here the graph of x squared
minus y squared equals 1 is the
hyperbola and by the way notice already
one significant change when we change
the sign here notice that in the case of
x squared plus y squared equals 1 our
curve essentially came in one piece now
you see our curve has two different
branch
and for the sake of uniformity for the
sake of well defined this let's pick the
branch that we will deal with to be the
positive branch meaning the branch
that's to the right of the y axis to
mimic precisely what we did in the case
of the circular functions what we do now
is what given any length T we started s
mock T off along the upper branch of
this double valued curve if T is
positive mark it off along the lower
branch if T is negative wherever T
terminates we call that point P and then
to complete our analogy with the
circular functions we define the x
coordinate of P to be the hyperbolic
cosine written cos h and pronounced cosh
cosh T is X and the hyperbolic sine is
the y coordinate of P and that's written
si n with an H hyperbolic sine
pronounced cinch in other words cosh T
is the x coordinate of P since T is the
y coordinate of P and in the same way
that x squared plus y squared equals 1
gave us the circular identity that sine
squared T plus cosine squared T is 1 the
fact that x squared minus y squared is 1
gives us the hyperbolic identity that
cosh squared t minus sinh squared T is 1
so again notice great similarities great
differences I'd like to make just a
brief aside to point out how in one
sense this difference isn't to
significance yet in another sense it's
very significant on the 1 notice the
following if you look at the equation x
squared minus y squared equals 1 and if
I can draw on your previous knowledge of
the square root of minus 1 just for a
moment for sake of illustration if we
think of I as being the number whose
square is minus 1 notice that another
way of writing x squared minus y squared
is to write x squared plus the number I
Y squared you see I squared is minus 1 y
squared is y squared this is just
another way of saying x squared minus y
squared is 1
again it's not that crucial but because
much later in the course when we study
complex numbers there is going to be a
rather nice identification between
hyperbolic functions and circular
functions as a prelude of things to come
notice that what we're saying is if you
plot x squared minus y squared equals 1
if you plot that in the XY plane
you get the hyperbola that we talked
about on the other hand if you change
the name of the y-axis to the I y-axis
notice that with respect to this type of
coordinate system the graph would be a
circle again just an aside to show you
structurally a connection between
circles and hyperbolas in terms of
complex numbers in that way these things
are fairly similar now to show you how
different a sign changes I thought you
might be interested in the following
little device take any two numbers a and
B no matter how different and form two
numbers one of which is half the sum of
a and B and the other is half the
difference of a and B it's a trivial
verification to show that the sum of x
and y is a and the difference X minus y
is B in other words no matter how
different a and B are we can always find
two numbers X and Y such that just by
changing the sign namely if we add the
pair of numbers we get one of the
numbers if we subtract them we get the
other just to make this a little bit
more vivid suppose for example a happens
to be one thousand and suppose B happens
to be four now there's no danger of
confusing these two numbers they're
quite different on the other hand notice
that half the sum is 502 and half the
difference is 498 you see if I add these
two numbers I get a thousand if I
subtract them I get 4 and therefore
notice that just by changing the sign
here I can effectively create a change
of from 4 to 1000 that I just mentioned
that to show why these people who say
things like all I was was off by a sign
that making us
mistake is very very crucial especially
if the answer later on has to be added
on to something else but at any rate I
didn't have to give this example except
that I thought it was a cute little
aside for you to notice from a more
practical point of view if we just go
back to these two graphs that we've
drawn notice that just changing the plus
sign to a minus sign radically changed
the shape of the curve that we were
talking about okay so at any rate then
this gives us the hyperbolic functions
and a very natural question to raise at
this time is why the hyperbolic
functions now why study them now why
didn't we do it before why did we wait
until we were dealing with exponential
functions the answer is that the
exponential functions give us a very
vivid way of reconstructing the
hyperbolic functions and the key lies in
the following fact it lies in the fact
that the derivative of e to the U with
respect to X is e to the U times du DX
in particular if I take the derivative
of e to the T with respect to T I get e
to the T if I take the derivative of e
to the minus T with respect to T
I get what et to the minus T times the
derivative of minus T with respect to T
that's minus 1 so the derivative of e to
the minus T is minus e to the minus T
well what does this have to do with
anything
notice that if I now construct a new
function e to the T plus e to the minus
T since the derivative of a sum is the
sum of the derivatives
notice that this result here tells me
that the derivative of e to the T plus e
to the minus T with respect to T is e to
the t minus e to the minus T ok now let
me do this operation once again suppose
I now take e to the t minus e to the
minus T and I differentiate that with
respect to T well the derivative of e to
the T gives me e to the T again the
derivative of e to the minus T is minus
e to the minus t minus x minus is plus
so observe that if I differentiate e to
the t minus e to the minus
I come back to e to the T plus e to the
minus T notice already how this starts
to behave at least a little bit like our
friends sine and cosine except again for
a little change in sign namely if I give
this function here a special name and to
make it suggestive I'm going to call it
C of T Cecil if to indicate cosine but I
don't want to write cosine because it's
not a cosine let me just call this
function here C of T and its companion
as you may guess I will call s of T C if
T is e to the T plus e to the minus T s
of T is e to the t minus e to the minus
T the this pair of functions has the
property that what the derivative of one
of them is always the other which is not
quite what sine and cosine did remember
if you differentiate the sign you got
the cosine but if you differentiate the
cosine you didn't get the sine you got
minus the sine so you see again a
similarity but not exactly the same
thing
nonetheless we get a little bit
suspicious about this we see that the
relief of C is s through the VESA C we
remember that there was a basic identity
involving sine squared plus cosine
squared we might get the premonition
that maybe there's some relationship
between s squared and C squared and one
of the best ways of checking out a
premonition is to just check it out I
mean let's just see what happens in
other words starting with this
definition of C this is a binomial let's
square it you see if we square it it's
what it's e to the 2t the first term
squared plus twice the product of these
two terms but e to the T times e to the
minus T is e to the 0 which is 1 plus e
to the minus T squared which is e to the
minus 2t
in other words putting this all together
the square of C is e to the 2t plus
twice 1 which is 2 plus e to the minus
2t similarly when we square s we get
exactly the same thing only with a minus
2 as the middle term rather than a plus
2 well now we look at C square
well and just by looking at this
expression any hope that C squared plus
s squared will give us a nice identity
should vanish because you see if you add
these you're going to get an e to the 2t
term in here in fact twice e to the 2t
here you'll get twice eetu the minus 2t
and only the two and the minus two will
drop out on the other hand should you
elect to subtract S squared from C
squared the e to the 2t terms cancel the
e to the minus 2t term cancels and we
wind up with what C squared minus s
squared is identically four and by the
way notice up to this point no use of
the word hyperbola okay however if you
think of the so-called unit hyperbola
the one for which x squared minus y
squared is 1 notice that C squared minus
s squared equals 4 almost has that form
well it has the form all that spoiling
it is the 4 on this side now you could
pretend the 4 was the 1 but that would
be cheating what we do instead is just
divide both sides of this equation by 4
observing that C squared T over 4 is
just C if T over 2 squared s squared T
over 4 is just s of t over 2 squared in
other words dividing through by 4 this
equation can be put into this form and
now you see we satisfy the basic
hyperbolic identity of this squared
minus this squared equals 1 by the way
since the season the essence may not
seem familiar to us what we can do is
what go back to the basic definition c
or c if t meant e to the T plus e to the
minus T therefore half of C of T is e to
the T plus e to the minus T over 2 s of
T was e to the t minus e to the minus T
therefore s of T over 2 is e to the t
minus e to the minus T over 2 and again
the reason I bring this out is that in
most textbooks
they simply define the hyperbolic
functions this way I find it a poor
motivation I don't find it easy to
motivate where are the clear blue sky
I you bring in a two in the denominator
all I wanted to see in terms of
motivating what's going on so far is
that if I just define a function to be e
of T plus e to the minus T and another
one to be e of t minus e to the minus T
I could have shown that the first
squared minus the second squared was
four and the motivation of putting the
tool in the denominator is for no
greater reason than to help us satisfy
the equation x squared minus y squared
equals one in fact this is now the
connection between what we were doing a
few minutes ago and what we're doing now
namely if I now call this cosh T and I
call this sin T do I get my basic
hyperbola namely suppose I take a curve
whose equation is given parametrically
by X equal cosh T and y equal cinch T
okay where caution cinch are now defined
as over here without any reference to
the hyperbola in the same way that we
could identify n-- the circular
functions in terms of calculus without
having to appeal to the circle what I'm
saying is suppose we had never mentioned
the word hyperbolic function up to now
we have developed a function called cosh
T a function called cinch T just from
these two relationships here if I
eliminate the parameter T here and then
we if I square both sides of this
equation of each equation and add I'm
sorry and subtract I get x squared minus
y squared is cosh squared t minus sinh
squared T but that I already saw is 1 in
other words this parametrically gives us
the hyperbola x squared minus y squared
equals 1 by the way let's make another
observation
notice that the exponential can never be
negative see e to the minus T is 1 over
e to the t which is still positive
notice that the cosh can never be
negative see e to the T is a positive
number e to the minus T is a positive
number
therefore notice that in this particular
relationship not only is the curve given
by x squared minus y squared equals 1
but since the
can never be negative it's also
characterized by X is positive and you
see that tells us what that what we're
getting this way is not the entire
hyperbola but just the branch for which
X is positive which is exactly what we
were talking about earlier in the lesson
again I leave further details of this to
the exercises all I want to do in
today's lesson is to get the flavor of
what's going on how we can invent the
hyperbolic functions without reference
to a hyperbola until we're all done see
I hope you see this juxtaposition we've
done two things here one is we started
with the hyperbola and showed how we
could invent this construction the other
is we started with the exponential and
showed how we could construct two
functions of the exponential which had
the property that they could be
identified with the thing that was
called the hyperbolic cosine and the
hyperbolic sine in other words we could
take either of the two approaches and
derive the other but I don't want to put
in all of those details here okay
at any rate to show you where calculus
comes in in terms of what I meant by
saying that as far as this course is
concerned we have now finished the
groundwork both with respect to
differential and integral calculus
suppose for example I now want to define
the hyperbolic tangent C y equals
hyperbolic tangent X how could I do that
well I mimic the circular function
definition I say okay I will define the
hyperbolic tangent to be the hyperbolic
sine over the hyperbolic cosine by the
way in the same way that one can show in
terms of geometric constructions on the
unit circle how one constructs the
tangent and the cotangent and the
cosecant and the secant etc one sine and
cosine are given it can also be shown
that we can construct these things in
terms of geometry from the hyperbola but
because that gets computationally
involved I've also saved those aspects
for the exercises in other words I'm not
going to worry about how you construct
the hyperbolic tangent given the
hyperbolic sine and the hyperbolic
cosine right now all I'm saying is
suppose you've made up this definition
and now somebody says gee
I would like to find the derivative of
the hyperbolic tangent of X what I want
to point out is that the recipes that we
need are no different from anything that
we've had before namely since the
hyperbolic tangent of X is since X over
cosh X I use the same quotient rule as I
used before namely to differentiate the
hyperbolic tangent I differentiate this
quotient how do we differentiate a
quotient
it's the denominator times the
derivative of the numerator well the
numerator is since X the derivative of
sin checks is cosh X that gives me a
cosh squared X over here minus the
numerator which is cinch x times the
derivative of the denominator well the
derivative of cosh X is sin checks like
is not a factor over the square for the
denominator now my basic identity is
that cosh squared minus sinh squared is
1 so this is just 1 over cosh squared X
and if I want to write this all on one
line I can invent the notation that the
hyperbolic secant is 1 over the
hyperbolic Oh cozy 1 over the hyperbolic
cosine in other words I can invent
notation like this but again the
important point is not so much what this
answer is but how I can derive it from
first principles and by the way in terms
of the inverse derivative once I know
that the derivative of hyperbolic
tangent is a square of the hyperbolic
secant I can immediately add to my list
of inverse derivatives namely I can just
have to write down
say there's an integral formula now have
but again all I want to emphasize here
is how the details take care of
themselves in the same way as always
once we have our basic definitions it
might be interesting just in terms of
cementing down what Sinjin cars look
like in the same way that we have talked
about sine and cosine it might be nice
to graph sinchon cosh and again notice
in terms of curve plotting how do we
plot y equals f of X the general
procedure was what always take the first
and second derivatives search you can
see what the slope is what the concavity
is etc the derivative of cosh is sinh CH
derivative of sinh is cosh by the way
again if these terms seem alien to you
you can always rewrite them in terms of
the basic definition in terms of e to
the X and e to the minus X and carry out
the differentiation in a straightforward
way well here's the interesting point
let's plot y equals cosh X notice first
of all that cost X is an even function
if I replace X by minus X all I get is
what e to the minus X plus e to the x
over 2 which is the same thing as I have
over here it's going to be a symmetric
function with curve with respect to the
y axis but again what do I do i compute
the derivative I can find out where the
derivative is 0 its 0 when e to the x
equals e to the minus X that happens
only when X is 0 when x is 0 this is e
to the 0 plus e to the 0 that's 1 plus 1
which is 2 over 2 which is 1 so in other
words the derivative is 0 when x is 0
and Y is 1 the second derivative is cosh
we've already seen that this can never
be negative so the second derivative is
always positive that means that the
curve is always holding water putting
all this together the curve y equals
cosh X looks something like this it's a
dangerous thing to say it sort of
resembles a parabola it's nothing like a
parabola except if we what I mean is it
has this type of shape notice it does
not oscillate it is not an oscillating
function like the cosine it doesn't
periodically this thing just keeps going
like this alright on the other hand how
can we plot y equals sin checks well I
guess we can come right back to here and
work from here the derivative of sinh is
cosh the cost is always at least as big
as one we found out therefore the slope
of sinh checks is always at least as big
as one and it's equal to one when X is
zero putting all these details together
what we find is what first of all the
Cinch is an odd function meaning if we
replace X by minus X we change the sign
see this is e to the minus X minus e to
the X which is the negative of what we
have over here but those again are
details which are easy for you to fill
in the graph y equals sinh checks look
something like this in other words it's
a very steep curve it's spilling water
and rising here holding water and rising
here curve is always rising again
another interesting thing to observe
here is that notice that when X is very
very large e to the minus X becomes
negligible and if e to the minus X is
negligible notice that both cinch and
cosh behave like 1/2 e to the X in other
words this term tends to drop out and
just to show you the contrast here I've
sketched in the curve y equals 1/2 e to
the X to show you how it splits the
difference for large values of X between
these two in a way and that as X gets
larger
both of these curves converge on y
equals 1/2 e to the X again I simply
want to mention enough here so that you
get the idea of how we can apply the
same old calculus to our new function
what I'd like to do in closing is to try
again from our point of view of being
engineering ly oriented to show why the
hyperbolic functions might have occurred
in nature in the same way that we tried
to show that the circular functions had
a natural outgrowth in terms of nature
you recall that the circular functions
were motivated in terms of simple
harmonic motions the circular functions
would have been invented when we talked
about motion in which the acceleration
was proportional to the displacement
in the opposite direction let's see what
happens when we work with the hyperbolic
functions see suppose now I have a
particle moving along the x axis okay
and I know this position that any time T
is since of K T where K happens to be a
constant what is DX DT the derivative of
Cinch
U with respect to U is cos u so the
derivative of sin CH Katie with respect
to T would be cosh K T times the
derivative of KT with respect to T which
is just K in other words the chain rule
again okay now knowing that the X DT is
K cosh KT
d2x DT squared would be what the
derivative of cosh K T is since KT times
the derivative of KT with respect to T
that gives me another factor of K and
therefore the second derivative of X
with respect to T is K squared since KT
now remember what cinch KT is we started
with the knowledge that since KT is X
therefore replacing since KT by where
it's equal to we wind up with what the
second derivative of X with respect to T
is equal to K squared X C no minus sign
here what what happens when we start
with the Cinch if an object were moving
according to the rule x equals cinch KT
its acceleration would be proportional
to the displacement but in the same
direction you see what that means that
means the bigger the displacement the
bigger the acceleration so the faster
the object keeps moving in other words
this thing would move in a faster and
faster rate away from the origin etc
that's not our main concern here what is
interesting though from a physical point
of view and we can use this as a summary
from a physical point of view is that
the hyperbolic functions serve as a
solution to the equation D 2 X DT
squared equals K squared X where K is a
constant the circular functions on the
other hand solved the equation D 2 X DT
which is minus K squared X in other
words from this point of view notice
again from a physical point of view that
the difference between the circular
functions and the hyperbolic functions
are again just the difference in sign as
I say this will be emphasized more in
the exercises the obvious next lesson I
think you can see it coming by this
stage in the game will of course be the
inverse hyperbolic functions and we'll
see why those are important next time
but until then goodbye
funding for the publication of this
video was provided by the Gabriella and
Paul Rosenbaum foundation
help ocw continue to provide free and
open access to MIT courses by making a
donation at ocw.mit.edu/donate